this chart shows the level of government
borrowing over the last 20 years the
skyscraper was building there or the
financial crisis but they've got nothing
on this this spike shows that the
government borrowed a colossal sixty-two
billion pounds last month that's the
largest number on record it's almost six
times more than in April last year when
11 billion pounds was borrowed and
almost three times the twenty two
billion pounds that was needed in April
2012 which was the peak of borrowing
after the financial crisis now it's a
consequence of two things
government support during the outbreak
and the impact of locked down on tax
receipts the job retention furlough
scheme is currently paying the wages of
8 million people and as so far cost 11
billion pounds and another 2 million
people have claimed self-employment
support that could yet cost another 6
billion on the other side of the
equation the economic slowdown has left
a 25 billion pound hole in government
income from taxes and so on now most of
that is v80 last April the Treasury
collected 12 billion pounds this April
it was actually negative - nought point
nine billion as businesses deferred
paying their VAT and the Treasury
rebated more money than it collected and
of course we are all spending less this
chart shows retail sales volumes they're
down a record 18 percent in April
spending on clothing and shoes was down
52 percent household goods down 45
percent those spending on alcohol and
tobacco was up two percent now the
consequence of all of this is an
historic level of debt what's clear is
that is going to be the biggest deficit
as a share of our economy that we've
seen in peacetime so it will be probably
larger than what we saw the height of
the financial crisis it will probably be
larger than anything we've seen since
the Second World War the irony of these
dreadful figures for the public finance
is they're actually a sign of the
effectiveness of the lock tower measures
and the economic support that's been
offered but now millions of jobs and
livelihoods depend on the government
being just as successful in restarting
the economy